so
um if you don't know what spell chess is
you're not alone because I don't really
know what it is either
but I think we'll just explore and
uh let's click this I think it's the
first step
do I dare read the instructions or
should I go in without reading them
how about I skim them there's two spells
okay that's simple enough jump and
freeze
players have limited spells they
recharge after a few moves
yada yada
so pieces become Frozen Wait how do
jumps work
jump applied to one square
so you can jump over that square
okay
simple enough
five two versus random
I haven't done this before if so
this will be interesting
I am playing against
Sam bust E4
so let's play E4
and these pieces are going to take some
time to get used to
I have no idea what opening will be best
in this game
so I assume these are my spells
so can I like if I
what happens if I like freeze this and
then take this
now the I assume the queen is frozen
oh but it's only Frozen for one move
oh
oh I have four left
yeah
uh oh
a little bit scared about this
wait what if I use my jump and take the
king
maybe that's not possible anymore
[Music]
yeah this is uh
this is again very new for me trying to
get the feel for this I think my
opponent is just
crumbling a bit hasn't used a spell yet
now getting forked
maybe I should have used my freeze there
how does the game end
oh Frozen pieces do not check or
Checkmate Kings
oh interesting
well is it is a bishop Frozen do they
freeze their own Bishop
oh the freeze only lasts for one move
okay so now I'm curious if I if I freeze
and then take the bishop
what's gonna happen
am I just gonna win now
because the king's Frozen
and then once this area is unfrozen I
tape
let's go okay
uh
so I feel like it's so easy to lose in
this game
like to forget about the fact that your
opponent can check you and then
freeze the area around the king
maybe the opponent could have
counterfeit
counter freeze
we didn't see the jump being used
um
let's just play again let's play
maybe I'll get a new opponent playing
say no more
this is probably very bad for my overall
like chess
ability it'll probably take some
adjusting
going back to normal chops
yeah I miss a doc doc chess is like
simple to understand
this is a bit more mind-bending
yeah for anyone confused feel free to
try and read like this block of text
maybe it's small on the stream layouts
but
is my opponent gonna try and play a cow
Bishop E2 is not the cow though
oh maybe I should have Frozen
I probably should use the freeze like
earlier in the game
hmm
wait I have to I was gonna play the move
and then use the freeze but I have to
use the freeze first and then play the
move so now I'm hitting the Knight
I should be winning the Knight next move
welcome back to choco
oh yeah we have the Frozen Rosen emotes
which
I guess is fitting for this position
except I'm not the one who's Frozen
there goes a knight
wait a minute can my opponent take and
then freeze my king
and my Knights
oh
I might be losing here
I don't have a counter freeze
opponent's taking time oh dear
no I can't I can't do that or that can I
jump
wait how does this jump work
if I put it
I have to read the instructions
the jump is applied to one square if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump
wait so can I jump and move into the
Frozen yeah because the rook's not
frozen so
this and then jump let's go I'm not
losing
okay that was a close call
so that was just a queen train
now the game continues so they have
their
oh they have their jump
and I have my freeze and they're
recharging their freeze
so I think I'm getting the hang of this
so if it's only one square
that's interesting
wait a minute can I just take and then
freeze
and then take and then GG
oh it's not GG
up one has one way to get out of it
similar to what I did to get out of my
predicament
oh this is actually kind of fascinating
there's like so many situations where it
seems hopeless but
oh no it is GG I was thinking The Rook
could jump over the pond but the Rook is
also Frozen
or wait is it GG because opponent can
use a counter freeze
I'm so confused
the point counterfeuses can I jump over
my Pawn to take this Pawn
I don't know how refreezing works
like if you have an ice cube you let it
paw and then you refreeze it
is it still the same Ice Cube
how does GG work
Gigi works like this GG
yeah so I think the game just ends when
you take the king similar to duck chest
I'm really curious if the opponent could
have like used the freeze
oh wow then it's double freeze and then
let's say move
uh move here
yeah then I would have my knight would
have been frozen white can take the next
move
because my freeze isn't recharged
let's play a quicker game let's play
three two
but it feels like I'm
getting a feel for this
yeah let's just freeze this territory
and
I feel like it's decent to use the
freeze earlier in the game
it also seems like there's gonna be some
possible tricks coming up
everyone has a provisional rating this
is such a new variant
oh
Okay so
oh wow that's almost almost checkmates
because I can't play B4
I can't block with any of those pieces
but I can use this this and then this
oh I feel so strong
yeah that was the point of Queen E2
Queen E2 is basically check
because I'm threatening to take the king
with the jump
oo okay I'll play Google
yeah so for people that are confused
this is really I mean it's still normal
chess it's just a matter of
understanding how the the two different
spells work
um so I think I've pretty much grasped
it
although it still takes some getting
used to
freeze it's just a three by three Square
that's frozen for a move
and then the jump is
one square that you can choose to jump
over
so I guess it wouldn't make sense to use
the jump to like move a knight
because Knights can already jump
I wonder who the strongest player in
this is
also can I just take the pawn oop
s
I'm used to duck chess where I take the
piece and then place the duck
but in this game I have to use a spell
and then make the move
um so let's just
let's play this
I'm playing the Irish Gambit
this is actually a real chess opening
that's just a little bit dubious
I have to watch out for the
like if if the opponent plays this and
then freezes
I guess I can counter freeze or I can
develop the Knight
oh did I post a YouTube video
I think I scheduled a YouTube video for
like a minute ago
I see the comment from yng warthog
tiny people get notifications for
YouTube
okay so my opponent's threatening to
take my king because they have the jump
but what they missed is I also have the
jump
and I'm going to jump over the pawn and
take the queen
and I just feel like such a wizard
I do apologize for the YouTube thumbnail
if it disturbs some people
um
can I play Let's Play wait a minute
opponent's gonna do this and then freeze
me
yeah
maybe I just do this
to avoid getting checked
and the thumbnail
um I actually use this software
um
it's like this new AI software I
discovered that allows first for face
swapping
so
I don't know how many people will notice
so closely the the details of the face
swap
I think black meant to freeze me because
I can just take this now
and
that's looking pretty good
uh oh
wait they just use their freeze now I'm
gonna use my freeze
I think that's GG
unless there's some magical spell I'm
not seeing but I don't think the jump
will save back in this position
[Music]
even if my King's counter-attacked I'm
I'm the first one to capture
okay
I'm enjoying this so far
yeah this is a thumbnail
I was inspired by there is like a post
on I think it was Anarchy chess of
Levy's face
on this image
so I was inspired to
also put my face on it
yeah the chin is very Giga Chad like
spooky ghost observing another game
except
oh okay this is the highest rated
opponent I've played so far in spell
chess
still undefeated
oh cool
thank you oh the
people don't see there is a little
message on top that said that I'm
streaming
uh do I play the ponziani no let's play
the opening I intended to play the
previous game
of
paraly or freezing and then taking
wait my opponent can play this and then
play a Stafford Gambit then I take take
we transpose into Stafford
oh a point wants to jump
so let's play this
that's so important to have a sense of
danger because it's so easy to forget
about the jumper the freeze
like they were also threatening to take
and then freeze me too so it's like two
different ways to win
wait what have they taken and freeze
everything
and then they're still threatening to
jump
but that's not happening
so let's play this
I'm realizing it's like
it's super dangerous not having the
the spell to like counter freeze
they could take and then freeze this
area
yeah ponziani theory is is developing a
little bit
wait what have I taken the
um freeze
which area do I want to freeze
maybe this area freeze and then take
I feel like I'm just scratching the
surface of like strategy in this game
like us like there's no one on the
planet that has more than like a week of
experience in this right
oops
wait I have this move though
oh I was very lucky
I could play the Queen H5 too
my queen H5
well Queen H5 is actually really Nifty
oh Queen H5 was a terrible move
oops
ah
it's okay though we're just trading
Queens
and actually I'll I'll recapture The
Rook so it's all a fair trade I think if
anything I'm winning material
let's use a jump
and I take the Rook
okay so my Rook just developed
so that actually worked out like Queen
H5 I think objectively was okay
but black still has a freeze so they
could freeze my rook and probably win it
oh but then I can counter freeze
oh I only have one
yeah what does this mean times one
so I mean I have one jump left
I actually don't know how it works when
it goes down to zero
so let's play this
I might be frozen
I actually don't know what's happening
here
I'm just trying to confuse the opponents
can you jump upon to promote
well Pawn's gonna only move one at a
time at least when you get close to
emotion
I guess pawns could jump
in such a way going to have to start
calling it The Rose and Gambit vs Gambit
quack
[Music]
yeah I want to like take and then freeze
but then black can counterfeits so I
think I just take
and then win the pawn
wait what
rosengan versus Gambit
yeah maybe that's just a fair Queen
train
oh you thought the Rook was a pawn yeah
it's not so often you can move a rook
out from each one when meeting the
bishop and pawn like this
okay
I think I'm gonna be winning on time
oh Point wants to do this
but again I can count your freeze
okay one more time GG
do we consider freezes as like pieces is
it worth to trade upon with freeze
I actually have no idea
like this is so new
that
I'm also just trying to discover the
strategy like I'm sure there's an
element and there's a huge element of
like concretes
tactical play
but then there's probably also the
element of like long-term positional
strategy too like should I be saving
oh I only got two jumps
ah so we start with two jumps in five
freezes
interesting
so maybe it's worth like saving the
freezes until later
are saving the jumps until later
oh
speaking of jumps
oh no
oh this candy is a terrible opening in
this game
oh it's a really bad opening
wait what do I do now
this
ah let's freeze
uh it doesn't really matter I just want
to freeze the queen and then play this
and then try and win the queen
now white has a very strong move here
we'll see if obese freeze can find it
man it's so easy to have these blind
spots
yeah I think there's one way to Save the
Queen
what's that saying God Save the Queen
what would God do
after White's move I'll I'll share my
thoughts
oh it's a counter freeze I guess I was
thinking Bishop B5
I forgot about the counter freeze
so let's play this
and then I guess I'm just kind of sad
here
okay
wow so we just traded frieza's basically
now I'm down a queen
oh man and and he wants to jump and take
I don't know if the jump replenishes
like after my next move
so I'll be safe
but it's still like if I move it's gonna
show is this jump gonna replenish
let's see
it does okay so I'm I'm very fortunate
to
have not allowed Queen Jake's King
but I'm in a lot of danger here
so after his next move my jump will
replant it or my freeze will replenish
ah so
this situation actually relates to one
of the comments from earlier
how much value do we put on the Spells
because I'm I basically have one extra
jump
but white has a queen for it
hmm
also how do I defend
there there there
man
that's not good there's no way to defend
I mean I could freeze but
and there's a counter freeze
and maybe I no 96 while I was Bishop A6
about 95.
I think I just played G6 and
just lose everything try and save my
king
this is pretty bad though
I think
I think my only hope is time
it's turning into a bullet spell chess
game hi Eric happy birthday oh thank you
separate team you have a great year
ahead
that's starting off well
as I drink my this is my Starbucks my my
free birthday drink from Starbucks
I got a a pumpkin cold brew
obese freeze taking a little bit too
much time
Bishop B4 or Bishop B5 I think I just
take that
I don't fully see the idea
yeah so now
maybe I'll play Bishop H6 is the
trickiest move
there's only two second increments
okay I I feel a little bit bad there
hey I broke 1600
I mean I was getting crushed Queen takes
Rook
who's the highest rated player
challenging me
okay let's play uh
[Music]
okay so I learned my lesson from the
previous game I think
maybe I can play a walrus
oh maybe I'll play a Stafford Gambit
let's see how Stafford Theory Works in
this okay opponent wants to take my
thing
I think I know enough not to blunder my
king
hmm
can I get away with this oops oops I
have to freeze first
and then do this
okay
no I'm not winning here there's I think
there's like one way for
white not to lose us
or one one idea to get out of the
predicament
I wonder
what's more valuable like the freezer
the jump
yeah okay so my Bishop is now Frozen
but I can play this to the fend
and now the point can't use the freeze
so they have to either take the bishop
or
or move the king
and now my freeze will replenish first
but then they'll their freeze will
replenish
right after mine
H3 is maybe coming
[Music]
I think I just defend
oh wait I just saw each three
ah
yeah I mean they're losing my night or
my Bishop
I guess I'll lose my Knights
Knight
oh thank you I so am I
or ISO aim
also uh I lose my knight but my
opponents
loses her Rook
it's a cool idea
fell for the date
okay now my jump hasn't replenished but
my freeze has
but so is my opponents
why can't I freeze and play 98 93
I think if I went for the freeze my
opponent would be able to freeze back
so it kind of would have canceled out
I'm realizing with this game like
freezes kind of cancel each other out
so jumps might actually be like the more
interesting thing
to use
although I guess I'm threatening to
I'm threatening to take and then
if the counter freeze happens
oh no it doesn't cancel each other out
because I can I can uh freeze
and then take the bishop
and then if the opponent counter freezes
a rook my queen will be able to move and
defend
I didn't take the Knight because two
things could have taken and I didn't I
don't think I had a easy way to defend
there
yeah I don't think we can use both
Spells at once
unfortunately
oh I have my jump spell oh I'm gonna win
I mean I'm gonna play this
and now when the queen takes I jump over
and take the king
okay
oh I feel Unstoppable
GG
okay I have time for one more game
so I'm looking for ratings
best reading it's not saying the ratings
though 1527
1544.
okay let's play this person
five minute Spell chance
Fallen Gandalf
sounds like a wizard name
okay so I've learned not to play the
scandi
I think the Stafford is okay though
what is
that's why trying to do
I'm scared that this is some opening
Theory
I have to be really careful here
I really gotta watch out for these jumps
maybe I'm planning to take and freeze
yeah I'm realizing the freeze is most
useful when you can follow it up with
like a strong move
oops
I lost a bishop
can I no if I freeze there's a counter
freeze
What if I
if I just play this
I guess we traded I traded a bishop for
my opponent's jump
so it's not the worst thing ever
I wonder if a jump like having a jump is
worth a minor piece
it's an interesting Gambit
hey
uh
I'll use my jump and take the queen
's have to be super powerful in this
game
with with the existence of the jump
uh do I freeze
probably not
although I could take and then freeze
maybe I'll take and freeze or a freeze
and take
like freeze and then take
so the idea is if the opponent counter
freezes my knight I can defend with
either Pawn
and there's no way to freeze
both pawns and the Knight because
they're outside the three Square radius
so I hope this makes sense
oh there's a question about Queen E6
earlier in freezing if my opponent
played Queen E6 I would have just
counterfe use a counter freeze
and prevent Queen takes King
I think not 100 sure but
pretty sure I would be okay there
yeah so now I can play F5
and basically we traded freezes but I
won a pawn so
that was a pretty good trade
now opponent is threatening to jump and
win my thing
so
probably king of uh
oh this could be annoying though
King E7
and play King F7
not sure the best way to do this
wait I don't have a freeze but my
opponent doesn't have a freeze either
okay so now I do have a freeze
take so if I take the freeze replenishes
but I think I'll
I think I'll use it
and try and win the knights
this game is very mind-bending
wait am I losing
I think my opponent had this and freeze
my king and Pawn
they maybe could have won there
but now I'm okay I can take here
actually I think I'll have to analyze
afterwards I'm pretty sure in that
situation I could have used a jump to
block the track
I was very close to losing there
man it's still so tricky though
so now it's probably time to like get
the queen into play I want to take the
pawn but the opponent can jump
oh but they have one jump left
so they are threatening to take the Rook
so how about this move
man so I really have to see like White's
things are looking at things
I should play C6 next just be solid
ooh
okay my opponent's trying to set up this
very devious tactic
but
the thing is they can't jump over two
squares they can only jump over one
square so
I
applying the jump to this Pawn won't do
anything
oh we both have our freezes laughs
oh it's double check so if I take the
bishop
I lose my king because opponent can jump
but thankfully I have
this this and jump over the pawn to take
the king
uh too strong
and it's so easy to blunder the king in
this game
opponent had Tunnel Vision on my king
good game
I want to analyze real quick
uh
I can turn off challenges
but there's a moment
so when I yeah when I took and froze
this area
my opponent could have played
this
or she could have played this
and froze this
and now I'm just losing
I think
I think earlier I thought I could use my
queen to jump but the Queen's also
Frozen
so yeah my my use of the freeze was a
big mistake
oh man
I could have jumped castled
after the bishop check
is Jump casting a thing
I didn't even think about that but I
can't jump I can't take my own Queen
when I Castle I don't think
now I have a I have a question like in
the opening
if I want to be fancy
is is this a legal move use a jump like
this it is
probably no reason to ever do that
but pawns that's only reason to jump
I guess with a pawn
or that's the only way to use the jump
for a pawn is to when you move the ponji
squares
yeah I wonder can you jump castle can I
play a game I can't archive
so I'm just curious
I just want to analyze a little bit so
here here
oops so here
you can remove an analysis board wow
next level
and then here
so I'm curious if like in this position
can we see a jump castle if I apply
the jump spell to B8
can black hassle here
so much suspense
no
we can't Castle
that's sad
so
can you jump on passant
I don't even know how that would work
I guess you could like there's a
situation let's say this is this
I could play this and then this
and then on passant is not legal
and that that should be an instant loss
or at least an instant bricking
because a pawn is Frozen
and then the next move like on Plus on
is not possible even if it's pre-moved
right pre-move on poisson
if not possible
anyway I have to go
thanks everyone for watching for those
that didn't see my latest Youtube upload
check it out
this is the thumbnail
it featured some uh some giga chats
oh also yeah let me uh let me do the
outro for YouTube
um if this goes on YouTube let me know
what you think about spell chess let me
know if you want to see more spell chess
or if this was overly confusing but I
had fun maybe I'll try and find some uh
some stronger competition
trying to improve my spell game also big
thank you to all the birthday wishes and
support thank you happy Stuart
don't need too much cake